[MUSIC]
We are now ready to learn how to search
for longest paths, not only
in simple Manhattan line grids but in
arbitrary alignment graphs.
Here's an example of a graph.
And, in this case, there is only one way
to move to these three nodes from the
source.
And there is also one way to move to this
node from the source.
But when we move to this node,
shown by the question mark,
there are actually four different ways to
move to this node.
Which one should we choose?
In this case, we actually
have four choices.
And as before, we choose the variant which
provides the longest path.
In this case, this path is the optimal
one.
And we know that the
optimal path from zero to the shown
node
has length 10.
We continue doing this and in the end,
we will construct this graph.
with every note marked by the length
of the longest pass and we will
learn that the length of the longest pass
from the source to the send is 29.
And as before,
we of course preserved the backtracking
pointers and that's why we
will know how to move back in this graph
and find the optimal path itself.
As a result, we now know how to
construct recurrency for the dynamic
programming in alignment graph.
If we define S(i,j) as the length of
a longest path from (0, 0) to (i, j).
Then in the alignment graph where
we have diagonal edges, corresponding to
the alignment gate, we have three choices.
We can either compute S(i,j) as S(i-1) plus
the weight of the vertical edge
into node (i,j) or S(i-1,j) plus
plus weight of the horizontal edge into (i,j)
or S(i-1,j-1)
plus the weight of the diagonal edge into (i,j).
And as a result, our recurrency for the
longest common subsequence problem
becomes particularly simple, because the
weight of all edges
in the longest subsequence problem is
zero.
Except for the right edges, that
correspend to matching letters.
And therefore the recurrency is simply
S(i-1, j) + 0
or s(i,j-1) + 0.
We can drop 0, of course, from this
equation, or
s(i-1, j-1) + 1, in the case, i-th symbol
in the first sequence
equals to the j-th symbol in the second
sequence.
and as before we, of course, preserve the
backtracking pointers for the longest
common subsequence.
And in this case, the red edge has weight 1,
all the other edges have weight 0,
and here are the backtracking pointers for
our particular problem,
finding longest common subsequence for
these two strings.
And we can move from the final destination
backwards using
backtracking pointers, and slowly but
surely, we will arrive to
the original node, initial node, and all
passes
that are traced by the blue edges,
represent the solutions to
the longest common subsequence problem.
To compute backtracking pointers, we have
three choices:
We can either record a backtracking
pointer as a vertical,
horizontal, or diagonal edge.
And as soon as the backtracking pointers
are computed we can write a simple program
that allows us to output the
longest common subsequence by, once again,
exploring three choices:
green choice, blue choice and red choice.
We have now learned that to compute a
score at a
given node, we need to consider all edges
entering into this node.
And the initial vertex of each such edge
is called a predecessor
of a given node.
And therefore, the currency for
computing the longest paths in an
arbitrary graph will be the following one.
Let's denote S(a) as the length of the
longest
path to node a, and to compute S(a), we
need to compute
the maximum among all predecessors of node A, and
we take maximum amounts of value scorer of
each predecessor plus
weight of the edge from this predecessor
to a given node.
So let's try to apply this approach to a
simple graph shown here.
We start from the initial node, and of
course, the length of the
longest path to this node is 0, and we can
compute two other scores
for two other nodes, 4 and 6, and now,
let's try
to compute the score for the node shown
by the question mark.
There are two edges entering into this
node.
Score of one of them,
of one predecessor is known as zero, but
score of another
predecessor is unknown, therefore before
we compute the score of the node
shown by the question mark, we need to
compute one more score, which is this one.
But to compute this score we need
to compute score in another vertex,
shown here.
But to compute score of the vertex, we
need to compute score for this one.
And to compute score of for this one, we
need to
compute the score that we had been trying
to compute some
time ago.
So we came to a vicious circle.
It looks like a catch-22.
We need to compute something that has not
been computed yet, but to
compute it, we need to compute something
else again and again and again.
Which tells us that the order in
which we explore nodes of the graph is
extremely important.
By the time the note is analyzed, the
score of all its predecessors should
already have been computed.
And if the graph has a directed cycle,
like the graph you just looked at, there
is simply no way to solve the problem.
Because a traveler may travel along this
directed cycle as long as he wants to.
And therefore, they limit attention to
so-called directed acyclic graphs, or
DAGs, which are
graphs without directed cycles.
In this slide, Batman is looking at a
directed acyclic graph.
And is trying to solve a difficult
dressing problem in the morning.
And topological ordering of a graph is
an ordering
of nodes of the DAG on a line such that
all edges in the graph go from left to
right.
There are different ways for Batman
to get
dressed in the morning, two of them are
shown here,
and each of them represents a topological
ordering because by the
time Batman needs to put something on,
all necessary
things already have been put on in this
particular case.
And, there is a simple theorem, that we
are not proving but you
can try to prove it to yourself, that
every DAG has the topological ordering.
And in fact, for our Manhattan grids,
there are many different ordering,
topological orderings.
And two of them are shown on this slide.
And after
we learned the topological ordering is
important,
we can design the pseudocode for the longest
path problem.
And it works like this.
We first topologically order the graph.
And then we update nodes in the order
given
by this topological ordering as described
on this slide.
What is the runtime of this algorithm that
we will use heavily
in the remainder of this lecture?
Well, when we run dynamic programming, we
look at every
edge in the graph just once to update the
node that this edge goes into.
And therefore, at the runtime of the
dynamic programming algorithm for finding
longest paths is proportional to the
number of edges in the graph.
And we are now
ready to look at different varieties of
sequence alignment problems
in biology.